I saw on the garba King what do you
really think of The Gargoyle King I mean
I think he's nice he's a great guy I met
him and his family
yeah he and his wife we're doing really
well little Twiggy kids yeah they love
the little Twiggy kids yeah I think he's
creepy I think people make fun of him a
little bit cuz it's just like sticks but
I'm like hey man if you saw that you're
telling me you wouldn't be scared how do
you see that run yeah I mean I think
it's super creepy that would give me
nightmares if that showed up like in my
room or something like that I find it
really disturbing okay I remember the
first time I saw it I didn't even
realize they had it set up and it was
dark and everything and I had just
meandered over there and I saw this
massive thing and I screamed and it
freaked me out I ran back around the
other side and they were like what
smiles like and I just saw I don't know
what episode it is when Betty is
painting all the The Gargoyle oh just
like a parrot merci yeah no that's
that's too much soon they'll join us
my cue
I think he probably has quite a hard
time moving around in that outfit I've
watched some of the episodes and I there
were definitely times where I went how
did he get inside Betty's house and no
one hear it either he put the costume on
like they're really quick or he shuffled
through the small back door or window in
a bunch of twigs just duck in with his
little wings whatever they're impressive
but were the gargoyle King is as
stealthy I would love to know who is
underneath that mask
I'd love to know may God have mercy on
our souls
that guy governor the king
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]